Should artists wastes
their time in art school?
No,
you shouldn't waste your time ever.
I think your question is,
is it necessarily a waste
of time to go to art school?
And I would say it depends very much on
the art school and they're on what you
do while you're there.
Um,
if you go to art school and you really
work at it like mad and you devote
yourself to it and you're in the library
and you're studying the great masters
and you're crafting your technique and
you're at a school where that's actually
possible,
then you can educate yourself and going
to art school can give you an identity
that allows you to investigate
that possibility free
from undue social pressure
for some period of time,
which is really the case with an arts
degree or something like that as well.
So if you can take advantage of it,
if you're disciplined enough and if you
can find a school that isn't completely
appallingly postmodern and and social
justice oriented instead of oriented
towards art,
then I don't think it has
to be a waste of time.
But I think there's a high
probability that it will.